it is a highly infectious disease that
preys on the most vulnerable
africa's boys and girls for decades the
unfortunate poster children
of the fight against polio but that
fight has for now
finally been won the continent today
declared free of wild polio
the natural form of the virus it's
hugely significant
and it's a it's a real triumph to
a vaccine campaign that has lasted for
many many years
and has involved you know people in all
countries
thousands of workers who were prepared
to go and administer vaccines to
children in very remote areas
people have lost their lives over this
poorly campaign
there are thousands in africa who still
live with the effects of polio
a crippling virus that can cause
irreversible paralysis within hours
as many as 75 000 children fell victim
to it as recent as 1996
but thanks to mass immunization programs
it's now been four years since the last
reported case
in nigeria but today's milestone doesn't
mean the virus can't return
it's still present in pakistan and
afghanistan
infectious diseases don't have passports
and for example we have seen
with refugee crises that all of a sudden
polio virus can creep in
we've seen this in in the palestinian
refugee camps for example
all of a sudden there was polio virus in
water supplies in israel etc
which is why the environmental
surveillance is really key of the
eradication program as well
although africa's beaten wild polio its
vaccine-derived form still persists
177 cases were identified so far this
year
but given the world's current
epidemiological challenges this will
nonetheless be a very
welcome moment iva bennett sky news